the clerk will now proceed to read the
orders of the day
protection from sex-based harassment in
public bill as amended in public bill
committee to be considered
now
before we uh get on to proceedings
um I remind members of the differences
between report stage and third reading
the scope of the reports stage debate is
the Amendments I have selected the scope
of the third reading debate to follow
will be the whole bill as it stands
after report stage uh members may wish
to consider these points and then decide
at which stage or stages they want to
catch my eye to make sure that their
speeches are relevant to the the stage
at which we are considering the bill so
we will start with new Clause one with
which it will be convenient to consider
all the other amendments Greg Clarke to
move new Clause one thank you very much
indeed Madam Deputy speaker and thank
you for your guidance on our proceedings
for this morning and I beg to move that
new Clause one in my name and the name
of honorable members from across this
house be added to the bill and in line
with your advice I will address my new
clause and the amendments in my name
specifically and also touch on the
Amendments of my honorable friend the
member for Christchurch and so I will
not rehearse the reasons for the bill
we've had a substantial debate of second
reading and a committee stage and I hope
that it may be possible to say more at
thirds reading new Clause one would
require the Secretary of State to issue
guidance to the police about the new
offense that is proposed in this bill
and that guidance must include but is
not limited to guidance on the defense
of reasonable conduct that is already
contained in the public order Act
now Madame Deputy speaker during our
debating committee some members were
understandably concerned that the
perpetrator of a an act of deliberate
harassment of a person on the grounds of
their sex could escape the consequences
of their actions uh by asserting that
they thought that their behavior was
reasonable and some members thought that
in particular the police risk being put
off from taking seriously the offense
because of that potential defense now in
fact in the public order Act
reasonableness is not in the eye of the
accused simply saying at the behavior
that was intentionally designed to cause
Allah or distress was reasonable does
not if I can kind of phrase provide a
get out of jail cut
but having clear guidance on this point
will make sure that the matter is
Crystal Clear to the police and all of
the authorities
the proposed requirement for statutory
guidance therefore provides that but is
not limited to that and so can the
guidance can include other matters
should it prove desirable to contain
them uh in the future uh now I wanted to
speak the guidance is addressed to the
police as is obvious from the terms of
the new Clause but in practice its use
is wider than that including the crown
prosecution service and that's because
once the statutory guidance is issued in
practice it's taken by all parties to be
authoritative indeed there's no point in
having separate guidance for the police
separate guidance to the CPS separate
guidance to any other body and this is
far from the only occasion in which
guidance is formally issued and
addressed to one particular audience
rather than being proliferated to
multiple actors for example statutory
guidance within the stalking protection
act 2019 is formally issued to the
police but was drawn up in consultation
with other statutory Partners including
the crown prosecution service and I
envisage and hope that the the minister
will be able to confirm that the same
approach will be taken in this case and
that the CPS would be involved in the
drawing up of the guidance to which my
new Clause refers
so it seems to me uh Madam Deputy
speaker reflecting on the uh the debates
that we had in committee that her
Amendment on the face of the bill uh
that guidance must be issued and that
must include into earlier status
requirements on the interpretation of
reasonable conduct is a pragmatic and
practical way of responding to the
points that were made in debate and I'm
delighted that the amendment has
attracted widespread support including
that of the government whose assistance
in drafting I gratefully acknowledge
say how long he expects it to be for
this guidance to be produced because I
have in mind that the guidance requested
last year on the draft code of practice
on the recording and retention of
personal data on non-crime non-hate
non-crime hate incidents that that took
more than one year to produce does he he
and this is a similarly long period and
can I also ask him to what extent he
expects his house to be able to have a
say on the content of this guidance well
I I was just my honorable friend I would
be very dismayed indeed if it took a
year to to drop uh such uh guidance and
that is a cautionary uh warning that he
he gives I hope it might be possible
when the minister responds to the
debates that he may give an undertaking
to produce the guidance uh with dispatch
having said a few moments ago that I
think it's right and appropriate that
the guidance is drawn up in conjunction
with the the CPS who will also as I've
just said uh have a regard to it that
will take some time but I would hope
that would be a matter of weeks rather
than a large number of months but the
minister
he and I are experienced in in office
and we know that only the minister can
can give that sure as to how long it
would take but I'm delighted that he
shares my impatience to to get on with
that can I turn to the amendments in my
honorable friend's name I'm grateful and
what about the ability of this house to
be able to comment on the guidance when
it's produced or in preparation of its
production well as my honorable friend
knows uh the nature of guidance is that
it is issued by the the government of
the day it is uh it is not it's not a
statutory instrument and we're not
proposing that it should be a statutory
instrument but again I see no reason why
I think it would be desirable for the
guidance to be shared not just with this
house but in public so that
guidance that is important should enjoy
the uh the uh the confidence and the the
wisdom of those that are intending to
use it so finally on that point with my
right honorable friends envisage that
the guidance first be produced in draft
form so that there's an opportunity for
people to be consulted publicly on it
well again see a matter for uh for the
minister uh but I can say to to him that
I would be not only content with that
but I think it would be a desirable
route to Tech on that so let me turn to
the amendments in the name of my uh
honorable friends and uh let me say for
the answer he's absolutely right in uh
in in seeking to ensure that legislation
in this house is properly scrutinized
and debated uh and the points that his
Majors including the ones that he's just
made are absolutely pertinent and and
valuable and as I hope you might expect
I've studied the Amendments uh very
carefully uh this week since he tabled
them so let me deal with them in in turn
amendments three to five in my own
friend's name I prefer the words due to
over because of uh in the bill now
precise language is important and uh he
and I I think share that view but I
don't think that this preference on his
part signifies any difference in
interpretation
uh because of the expression because of
is the expression extensively used in
other existing legislation on the
statute book for example the consumer
rights act in section 66 4 refers to
circumstances in which someone suffers
loss or damage and I quote because of
the dangerous state of a premises
because of rather than due to and
perhaps with more immediate relevance to
our discussions this morning the
equality act uses because of rather than
due to for example schedule 11 paragraph
three five of that act on school
admissions refers to circumstances in
which a school and I quote does not
admit a person as a pupil because of the
person's sex rather than due to the
person's sex now it may well be that my
honorable friends use of language is
more elegant than that contained in the
laws already on the statute book but I
hope that he will agree with me that
there is some virtue in linguistic
consistency in the law and that is the
the reason behind that choice of words
now my honorable friends Amendment uh
number four clarifies that it does not
matter if a in specified in the bill a
being the perpetrator of the offense in
question is a man or a woman
and although a majority of reports of
public sex-based harassment have been by
men towards women the bill applies
totally equally to both sexes and at no
point does the bill mention anyone sex
there is no ambiguity in the bill on
that point
but if my honorable friend is concerned
that in practice this may not be clearly
understood for example by the police it
may be a candidate for inclusion in that
statutory guidance to which we've
already referred and as he will recall
uh the guidance
specifies the interpretation of
reasonable conduct but is not limited to
that and so if uh turns out to be
perhaps after taking soundings with the
public some ambiguity in people's minds
if not on the face of the bill there is
the opportunity to address that
amendments two and six uh in my
honorable friends today would introduce
a concept of subsidiarity and Primacy if
I can uh call them that in other words
an offense would be committed only if
the sex-based harassment was the primary
uh motivational aspect of the behavior
rather than one of a number of aspects
now I completely understand the point
that my honorable friend is putting
forward but I would say two things in
response first of all one of the
purposes of this bill is to bring in
line harassment on the grounds of sex
with the existing law as it affects
other protected characteristics such as
for example race and so to take that as
an example to be guilty of the
aggravated offense of public harassment
on the grounds of race does not require
the racial elements uh to be the primary
element of a torrent of abuse that one
person might direct at another
nor is public racial harassment
defensible on the grounds that racist
harassment was merely a secondary aspect
of the behavior in question and indeed
not only is the the argument of
consistency that this bill seeks to
address but in this case I think it is
right that it is framed in that way
because racist abuse shouldn't happen at
all and the law should be clear on that
and I think that applies equally to
harassment on the grounds of someone's
sex so for reasons of consistency with
the the established law elsewhere and in
my view what is right I don't believe we
should introduce a special category of
Primacy filter for Primacy on the
grounds of sex that doesn't apply
already to race and the other offenses
that already have this protection
now Amendment seven and uh six uh in my
honorable friends uh name would delete
references to and I quote all presumed
sex
now the the current treatment in the
bill as drafted uh is again drafted to
be consistent uh with the law as it
applies in other contexts and
particularly uh to protected
characteristics so for example to use
the example of uh of racial uh
harassment that I mentioned uh section
28 of the crime and disorder act 1998
makes it clear that an offense is
racially aggravated if the offender
demonstrates hostility and I quote based
on the victim's membership or presumed
membership of a racial group
it's not always possible with a hundred
percent accuracy to determine a person's
race or sex in a public place indeed
Shakespeare would have been robbed of
many a dramatic plot line uh where it
otherwise
but that does not mean that it should be
acceptable intentionally to hurl abuse
at someone who turns out not to be of
the sex that was assumed any more that
it would be acceptable to scream racial
abuse at someone in public who turned
out not to be of the race that the
perpetrator presumed them to be
therefore again for reasons of
consistency with the existing law and
for reasons of Justice I think the
drafting of the bill has it right
finally my honorable friend in Amendment
nine our president in his uh earlier
intervention seeks to specify a
commencement date of the 1st of August
this year for this legislation to come
into effect and I am very grateful to my
honorable friends impatience to get on
with changing the law and he's quite
right in in all seriousness that if
Parliament passes legislation then it
should that signals the intention of
Parliament that the law should change
and the government should not then act
as a break on the law being changed in
practice indeed it would be
unconscionable for it to sit on the on
the statute book uncommenced and
therefore unusable to the police and
courts who those that might be watching
these proceedings or reports of it will
have a legitimate expectation uh that if
this bill passes that the law has been
angel will change shortly
however
should this bill be approved by this
house today as all colleagues we then
need to go to the House of Lords who's
procedures and timings are not always
clear to at least this member of this
house
and if my new Clause requiring statutory
guidance to be issued is inserted by the
house as we have discussed a few moments
ago that will take some time especially
if we provide an opportunity to to take
soundings on it before it is adopted and
so I fear that the first of August may
be a little too
specific and early to be on the face of
the bill for when commencement must be
made by but I I don't want to in any way
separate myself from the motivation of
my honorable friend in this quite the
reverse and should this bill attract the
favor of the house and the other place I
hope that instead my honorable friend
will join me in pressing the government
today to commit in seriousness to
commencing the legislation as soon as is
practically possible and should that a
commitment that I hope might be given
turnouts not to be enacted in practice I
hope that he will bolster my efforts
given his considerable experience of
leave success in this uh to join me in
harrying the government at every
opportunity to and induce her
relentlessly until this legislation is
commenced so including I'm very grateful
to my honorable friends for his uh
thoughtful and episodes amendments I
hope you can tell that uh I've seriously
considered uh their effects and I think
in uh in no case uh am I antipathetic to
uh to the the quite reasonable questions
uh that he raises about them but I do
think that they have uh answers in the
current uh drafting of the bill with the
amendment uh that I am moving today so I
hope that at the end of this debate uh
he'll be feel able uh to withdraw them
and to should circumstances arrive join
me in uh continuing a campaign for for
great dispatch on the part of the
government so Madam Deputy speaker I beg
to move the amendment and the new clause
in my name
new course one guidance
the question is that new Clause 1 be
read a second time at Stella Creasy
thank you thank you Deputy speaker
um I Rise as the person who tabled the
original amendments in committee that I
think have prefigured new Clause one to
recognize this as the best of parliament
but actually when we come together to
write legislation that we believe will
make a positive and constructive
difference to people listening to each
other's concerns recognizing the
positive process that scrutiny can play
can bear fruits that we can all support
so I want to welcome and support new
Clause one as that recognition that
there was a concern and an issue with
the concept of reasonableness at the
heart of public order offenses let me
just clarify what I mean by that because
this legislation is about harassment
other forms of harassment legislation
have always had within them a test that
somebody's Behavior cannot be considered
reasonable if a general opinion would be
that their behavior was unreasonable in
layman's terms when it comes to the
harassment that we're talking about that
if somebody were being apologies
followed down the street and shouted at
particularly about their sex or their
presumed sex even if that person were to
claim it were reasonable a court a
magistrate should be able to say that is
patently not and you should not be able
to evade prosecution under this
legislation accordingly however because
this was originally based on public
order offenses those distinctions about
whether somebody ought to know their
behavior was unreasonable were not
contained within the public order
legislation it is very welcome to me
therefore that the government has
listened and agreed to put out guidance
that will consider this point and I hope
in setting out what I believe that
guidance should cover that will be a
helpful Guide to the government and
perhaps answer the genuine queries I
know from the member for Christchurch
about whether they could be involvement
in it because for many of us getting
this right speaks to the heart of how
this legislation will be the effective
Freedom that we hope it will deliver
particularly for women but not exclusive
for women because we know it as women
who who are overwhelmingly reporting the
kind of instances that we're talking
about in this legislation but one of the
challenges will be that initial decision
whether or not somebody has committed an
offense and many of us are extremely
used to the idea that it is our reaction
to somebody's provocation rather than
their provocation that is the challenge
here so what new Clause one will do I
hope is recognize that in comparative
inconsistency with other forms of
harassment legislation a defendant who
argues that their behavior is reasonable
should not be a reason not to proceed
with a charge I think this I want to be
very clear about this because I could
understand why people would be concerned
nobody is suggesting that the reasonless
defense should not remain what we are
arguing is that that should be a matter
for the courts or the magistrates to
decide whether Behavior was reasonable
rather than the defendant so in setting
out that guidance I hope the government
will give weight to the idea that the
presentation of a reasonless defense
which we know happens quite frequently
in harassment cases but we recognize
hasn't necessarily happened with public
order offenses to date will be set out
that it should not be a matter that
deters the CPS or indeed deters the
police from seeking to proceed with a
prosecution and in that sense it would
be consistent with the guidance for
example on the serious and organized
crime and police act 2005 or the
protection from harassment Act 1997.
can I also then in setting that out
agree with the member for Tunbridge
Wells about some of the other amendments
I've been put forward today about the
importance of consistency in the law and
just add my support to the argument that
he has made about retaining presumed sex
within the legislation because the most
important thing about this legislation
is that we turn the lens from the
behavior of victims and behavior of
women in particular because we know
although this legislation covers both
men and women and indeed covers both
male and female perpetrators it is women
who will particularly benefit from
clarifying that street-based harassment
is unacceptable and is illegal already
and therefore should carry a higher
penalty if it is targeted in this way
that too often it has been the behavior
of the victim that has been called into
question in deciding whether to
prosecute and so what this legislation
does and why it is important that it is
written in this way is to turn our
attention back to the perpetrator were
we to have such loopholes whether it's
around reasonableness whether it's about
the status of the victim we could
inadvertently undermine the capacity of
the police and the CPS to be able to
secure those outcomes so I I recognize
the attempt to the member for
Christchurch to test the legislation and
I hope if he'd had read the scrutiny
that was given to this legislation in
committee he would have appreciated that
too because that's where new Clause 1
has derived from but I hope you will
understand where our many of us feel
that this change and those changes would
actually undermine this legislation
because it would mean that it would not
be as clear that our thought our sole
concern is on those people who harass
and intimidate and abuse other people in
public and who aren't doing it because
they are focused on the sex or the
presumed sex of the person in question
who is the victim and the important
thing that we want to send bypassing
this legislation is that those existing
crimes should not be diminished they
should not be ignored they should not be
seen as part of everyday life and that
we should address them so it's all I
wanted to say Madam Deputy speaker as to
say the person who originally came up
with the amendment that I think has led
to new Clause one and to recognize this
cross-party working in wanting to get
this legislation right and I hope that
those people who had concerns about
whether it was new Clause one or indeed
the other drafting of the legislation
will see the benefit in having had these
discussions but also the outcome in the
legislation as it is now drafted will
indeed benefit many of our constituents
as a result
uh Sir Christopher Chu um Madame Deputy
speaker it's a pleasure to to follow the
honorable lady who I know takes a great
interest in this particular uh subject
and I'm delighted that she has included
in her remarks a reference to the fact
that this legislation applies uh to men
who are victims equally as it applies to
uh women who are victims and one of my
concerns when looking at the report of
what has happened in committee was that
I don't think there was even a mention
of men and boys involved in in being the
victims and I wanted therefore to ensure
that emphasis was given to the fact that
this bill is uh applies to men and women
uh equally and I was grateful to my
right honorable friend for emphasizing
that point and saying that perhaps if
need be this could be included in the
guidance which is produced for
prosecutors
but can I just emphasize that
the the extent to which
men are being sexually harassed is
significant and I've got here a report
from the diversity
dashboard
which makes clear that sexual harassment
in the workplace is widespread and that
women suffer the most
but it also makes clear that a
significant percentage of men are also
victims of sexual harassment
and according to the nursing times
very many people don't report to their
employer that they've been harrised and
only 17 percent of sexily Harris male
nurses report it to their employer
overall female nurses are more frequent
subjects of sexual harassment but sexual
harassment statistics by gender tell us
that men aren't spared either and indeed
51 of the male respondents to the
nursing times survey said that they had
been sexually harassed that's a very
high percentage and research shows that
when a man suffers a sexual assault in
the workplace a woman is a perpetrator
in 76 percent of the cases
and so and it's also
um apparently the nursing times
established that it's very and it I
quote it's worrying and insensitive that
such behavior is seen as a joke when it
involves male victims
and that's why although men are
overwhelmingly responsible sexual
harassment against uh women
um we also need to take into account
that uh men are on the receiving end of
this as well and the reason I think this
is very important at the moment
is because of a growing belief among
experts including those who are in the
professions relating to Psychiatry and
psychology about the
impact of sexual Politics as it's called
on young men and you may Madam Deputy
speaker see in the article in a recent
copy of The Spectator magazine by a gus
a Carter in which he refers to
masculinity having been in crisis
and that it is now in in crisis and uh
that the polling company yougov has
found that just eight percent of people
have positive views of white men in
their twenties by far the lowest of any
ethnicity or age group and that males
are routinely presented as inherently
dangerous aggressive and animalistic
incapable of controlling their own
instincts and he he refers to the fact
that on public transport government
adverts announce that staring is sexual
harassment and he says us blokes can't
even be trusted to use our eyes properly
Madam Deputy speaker I think this is a
very serious aspect of this whole debate
around that harassment and as I prefer
to put it basically a common decency
standards of behavior and politests
about the consequence of the uh in a
sense the sexualization of this
harassment
is that it's having an adverse effect
upon the young males and teenage boys
are being
routinely disciplined by their schools
in circumstances where their female
counterparts are are not and
um that
there's one there's one teacher who a
former female teacher who left the
profession last year is quoted in this
article saying buyers are now seen as
potential perverts
there was this obsession with the
victimization of women I thought we'd
been getting somewhere with sex and
relationships teaching the children to
teach people with to treat people with
respect but that has been totally set
back
I won't go into all the other points
that are are made but
um
one point I think is worth is relevant
to this debate and that is there there
seems to be an inability to hold two
nations in our heads that sexual assault
is bad
and that treating men as inherent sex
pests is also bad
and a reasonable worry about assault
appears to have morphed into an
Institutional misandry there is a lack
of recognition that as with all crimes
the proportion of perpetrators is
Vanishing near small the awful behavior
of a few is leading to the mistreatment
of all and the consequences of all this
and unless we're extremely careful with
the language to it that we we use a
Madam Deputy speaker is that the
situation which is already bad is in
relation to the mental health issues of
boys and young men is going to get even
worse since 2017 the NHS has found that
the proportion of buys with probable
mental health issues has increased by
more than 50 percent and now to nearly
one in five the suicide rate for buyers
aged 15 to 19 has more than doubled over
the past decade
and the child psychologist Julie Evans
has said that she thinks the pendulum
now has swung too far in the other
direction boys came out of lockdown into
this slightly hysterical atmosphere
don't touch that's inappropriate that's
assault and they're being treated as
guilty until proven innocent and this
article which I think is a very uh
telling article goes on then to say well
what are we going to do about this are
we going to recognize that uh young men
age 18 to 24 are are more likely to be
unemployed significantly more likely to
be unemployed and similar age group for
for women and that women are
outperforming men in in University and
you've got the problem of workless men
living with their parents and almost
being
discouraged or intimidated into not
going out onto the streets and not not
only not finding jobs but not finding uh
girlfriends and so on there's a there's
a really serious problem of developing
for us and that's why I thought it would
be important to put down uh this uh
amendment to try and and put that
balance right and I'm grateful to my my
right honorable friend for recognizing
uh the the significance of that and even
are they honorable I say even if the
honorable lady opposite I see this too I
accept this I hope that when she makes
remarks in the future on this subject
she always emphasizes that this is not
just a one particular group of victims
but um people in general of both sexes
turn into some of the other amendments
that I I put down which were designed to
develop a debate um Adam Deputy speaker
and I think we've we've we're we're
having
um that debate
a dealing first of all with the with the
time scale for this um and the the the
fear that the guidance uh will be much
delayed I'm not sure that actually
the requirement to produce the guidance
is necessarily a reason why the bill
couldn't come in the ACT couldn't come
into into law if the guidance it might
the guidance were fully because these
offense this offense will still be
created and the guidance would would
follow and it's not conditioned upon the
guidance being produced first so I don't
think that's really an adequate reason
on the part of the government for and
not accepting a specific date of
implementation my right honorable friend
uh now generously says well I try to
keep an eye on on some of these things
and one of the reasons that I put a
specific date uh into uh Clause 2 is
because I had a similar experience in
relation to the
bill brought before this place by my
right honorable friend as a member for
East Yorkshire on the B use of parking
rules and by Rogue parking companies and
we he brought forward this bill and I
suggested that the guidance that was
going to follow from it should be have
to be delivered within a particular
specified period of a time and that if
it wasn't the legislation wouldn't take
effect and I'm afraid to say that as of
today and I think we'll talk about two
years back the legislators still not
actually come into effect and if the
amendment that I put down has actually
been accepted by my right Uncle friend
who was sympathetic to it but was
persuaded by the government to
encouraged me to to withdraw it in order
to protect his bill I I just I just
quote that as a as a current example of
the the the problem where we we leave it
to the government to decide uh when and
if such legislation is actually going to
come into effect and I know that at the
moment when perhaps my right honorable
friend in responding to this will will
deal with the the issue around
prisons and a number of prisoners that
there are like one can understand that
the the government might be nervous
about the the fact that one of the
consequences of this legislation might
be that more people would be sent to
prison certainly that was one of the
objections put forward by a previous
government to suggestions that we should
introduce uh more severe
well more more severe penalties for
people who were convicted of causing uh
death by a dangerous uh driving and and
the arguments put that this was going to
result in a particular number of extra
prison places having to be uh used but I
hope that the minister and responding
will say that the issue about the number
of people in prison is not relevant to
this this uh debate because surely what
we need in in our legal system is that
law should take its course and people
should not be excluded from punishment
in prison if that is what is is merited
just because we we don't seem to have
enough room in the in the prisons if we
haven't got enough room in the prisons
we either need to remove from those
prison some of the people who are still
on
um indeterminate sentences
um which uh I think is pretty unjust or
or and or we we need
um to build some more uh prisons but
that's so that's why I think it's
important uh to put a fixed uh date into
the bill and I've chosen arbitrarily at
the first of August 2022 but actually
it's not that arbitrary because I was
assuming that uh the normal rule will be
two months after rather sent and that
this bill all other things being equal
will get through the other place uh
before the end of that period
turning to
um the the other
um amendments that I've I've put down
the issue about because of all due to
and that is I concede um uh we can dance
on the head of a piano in relation to
that um and but I'm grateful to my right
honorable friends for having uh looked
at that
um in relation to the
Amendments about
um
Primacy
you see my understanding when I first
looked at the bill was that Clause 1
actually meant that
um you for the purposes a a
close one a person is guilty of an
offense under the section if a commits
an offense under section four a and a a
carried out the conduct referred to in
section 4A because of the relevant
person sex or presumed sex and I assumed
that that was
um would be the soul or reason for that
behavior and in discussing it with my
right honorable friend I I thought that
that was his own understanding of his
build that
um there wouldn't be any other
um subsidiary reasons or or reasons
which will be taken into account but
then I looked at
um the next
clause and it says that
subsection three a it says for the
purposes of subsection 1B the one to
which I've just referred it doesn't
matter whether or not a also carried out
the conduct referred to because of any
other factor and I couldn't understand
why that any other Factor had been
introduced because it seemed to me to be
a rather redundant and it undermined the
contention which
um my honorable friends my right hand
over in the city had when drafting this
bill that it should be
um
it should be clear that this was the
primary
um if not the sole uh reason for the
conduct referred to and
um that um my right on Orphanage has
used a slightly different explanation
today as to uh why he he he's unhappy
with my amendments an exciting various
precedents from other acts and claiming
consistency but I'd be grateful to the
minister when he responds to this debate
if he can spell out whether he does
accept as that the conduct carried out
because of the relevant person's sex
must be the main reason
um otherwise there will not be a offense
being committed under the provisions of
this bill and if he's able to spell that
out and perhaps it will be repeated in
in the guidance sin um I I will go home
as a as a happy bunny relatively
speaking a Madam Deputy speaker and and
actually on that note I I I I have to
say that I think as as I'm speaking here
that it's very moments the the other
place is debating the third reading of
my private members a bill on mobile
homes pitch fees uh and changing the
rules from RPI to CPI and so I hope that
I will certainly me be able to go home a
happy bunny on on the basis of that
getting a third reading in the other
place and I'm most grateful to my uh the
the note my Naval friend Lord adenium
Lister for taking it through that that
house
but that's a by way of a bit of an aside
um Madame Deputy speaker can I can I
just say that the the issue then comes
as to I I put in Amendment seven and
Amendment eight uh talking about sex or
or presumed sex it seems to me that if
you are in the business uh and I hope
that not many people are of
um harassing people on the basis of
their their sex and they think that
they're harassing a man uh or they're
Harrison a woman and then it turns out
that the person there harassing is not a
man but this turns out to be a woman or
vice versa
um then it seems to me that that
um is the amount of alarm or distress
that's going to be caused by the person
on the receiving end is going to be
significantly reduced
um if the person on the receiving end is
not the person of the sex that was
intended by the person who was making
those harassing say I'll give away right
onto a friend first I'm very grateful
it's my honorable friends and I don't
seek to quarrel with him but um but in
the analogous situation in which a
person uh with brown skin relatively
dark-skinned were the subject of a
humiliating
tolerance of racial abuse in these roots
but actually happened to have a skin of
a relatively dark pigment but was not a
member of a racial group I don't think
that would diminish the the impact and
the and the offense uh intended by the
person and surely the same would apply
uh in this case and actually the person
on the receiving end would feel a
humiliation and the perpetrator would
have exactly the same intention well
expect my right on a friend I think he's
conflating to dissimilar situations
because in the situation he's describing
that is already an aggravated offense
and and what we're talking about here is
offenses which are not aggravated indeed
it's because they are not regarded as
aggravated offenses and thereby
qualifying for greater punishments
that's why this bill has been brought
forward and so I I think it's it's
a mistake to try and equate a situation
where it already is an aggravated
offense with a situation which we've got
on the face of of uh this bill because
if you are
um uh harassing or or making um
remarks to somebody and you in the
mistaken belief that the person you're
trying to insult is a woman and it turns
out that the person's a man and then it
seems to me that there's a there's a
mistake and that's going to end them
probably it's still going to enable you
to be convicted of
um a public order offense
but it won't be a public order offense
because because your behavior is because
of that person's sex it's it's semantics
I prefer I I I I'm prepared to concede
but but that but that is why I brought
forward that particular uh Amendment and
The Honorable general for giving away
and in respect of his comments prior to
the intervention of my honorable friend
from Tunbridge Wells
was he saying that misgendering somebody
was going to cause less offense to them
as opposed to Greater offense because to
my mind any sexual burst harassment
whether it be misgendered or correctly
gendered is still going to cause offense
foreign
I have avoided up till now Madam speaker
getting into the debates about the
difference between sex
and gender and so I'm not going to rise
to the bait is that my honorable friend
has given me to try and develop uh
arguments around that this bill I think
commendably
is specific to sex and it leaves out
gender and it's I I so I'm going to
leave it at that if that's all right
with my my honorable of friends but I
think this brings me uh to the the the
conclusion of of my remarks I'm not
going to at this stage say uh what I'm
I'm my intentions are in relation uh to
uh these amendments until I've heard
from the minister which I hope Madame
Deputy speaker you will think is a
reasonable approach to take
uh
Shadow secretary secretary annalize dots
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
and I want to say first of all how
pleased I am to see this bill finally
making its way through the house today
and I want to thank all of the
campaigners who've worked tirelessly on
this issue obviously the right honorable
member for Tunbridge Wells and all of
his engagement
um that of the civil servants of course
we've also been working with him on this
and indeed my friend from walthamstow
and the many other members in this house
who have contributed to discussions on
this subject for such a long time and as
we near the end of women's History Month
2023 this bill is a welcome step in the
right direction and perhaps if I may
Madam Deputy speaker I would like to
pull us back to the main subject at
issue which is around public sexual
harassment it does remain a major
problem in our society plan
International UK found three quarters of
girls and young women aged 12 to 21 one
experienced a form of sexual harassment
in a public space in their lifetime
those numbers actually increase for
disabled women and girls and women and
girls from a blockation or another
minority ethnic backgrounds and actually
the impact this harassment is shocking
and I think it perhaps is worth just
reminding the house about this as we
discussed this bill
in 2020 the Girl Guides found out that
80 of girls and young women feel unsafe
from the right on their own increasing
to 96 percent of young women aged 17 and
18 months actually ordered just a
reminder that we at this stage we are
discussing this amendment there'll be
I'm sure a very good opportunity for a
third reading for The Wider issues but
on that at this point we're just doing
the report stage if the honorable lady
prefers to wait a third reading
absolutely fine
in that case Madame Deputy speaker I
would just say the reason why I
mentioned those points was in relation
to the new Clause that has been
introduced
um and the other amendments I believe
that the most honorable member for
Tunbridge Wells has set out very clearly
the rationale as has indeed my honorable
friend uh for Waltham so spelling out
why yes we do require to have guidance
we all hope it will come speedily but
also why it is actually important this
legislation is consistent with other uh
acts in this area and therefore I do
hope that the house will bear those
remarks in mind when deciding how to
vote thank you uh Minister Kristen
thank you madam Deputy speaker it's a
great pleasure to speak to these uh
amendments before the house at this
report stage let me start by saying that
I'm very grateful to my right honorable
friend the member for Tunbridge Wells
for his new Clause one and Amendment one
I'm happy Madam speaker to take this
opportunity uh to formally confirm that
the government does support those
amendments as my vulnerable friend has
set out this Clause would require
ministers to publish statutory
guidelines guidance for all police
forces to which those forces would have
to have regard that guidance would in
particular need to include material
about the reasonable conduct defense
which has been the focus of so much uh
discussion I know that there has been
some concern expressed I think by the
member for walthamstow and others that
uh a subjective interpretation of the
reasonable conduct defense might be
adopted by defendants in an attempt to
uh repudiate responsibility for their
actions or to avoid uh conviction it is
the view of the government that
um what constitutes reasonable conduct
can be defined objectively with regard
to their conduct and without needing to
have regard to somebody's uh internal
thought processes however we do agree
that in order to be completely clear
about this point and to remove any
ambiguity
um this guidance would be valuable which
is why we're happy to support the right
member for Tunbridge Wells uh new Clause
one and Amendment one
uh it would of course will of course be
possible for many other people to refer
to this guidance besides just the police
including of course uh the crown
prosecution service who we would expect
to be operating on the same basis as the
police when they um prosecute these uh
offenses
um we uh just to respond to a very
reasonable question uh quite rightly
asked by another member for Christchurch
we do of course
um want to get this done as quickly as
possible I certainly uh would not want
or expect this to take anything like as
long as a year
um which I remember referred to
um in his uh in his speech in a
different context and I would hope this
can be accomplished in a matter of
months now the member for Honorable Men
for Christchurch also said that this is
something that should be subject to
input and scrutiny I'm sure the
information would agree with that to
make sure that it's constructed in a way
that is proportionate and reasonable and
so I think that I would therefore expect
that uh opportunities will be provided
to interested parties to provide that
comment and I'll give consideration
to whether or not we should have a
formal consultation process on the
guidance but of course we should be
mindful that if we do that it will
obviously introduce
um additional delay but given that um
Point has been essentially raised we'll
give it thought and we'll strike the
right balance between getting this done
quickly which everybody wants but also
making sure interested parties uh both
in Parliament and of course outside
Parliament and have an opportunity to
input into the construction of this
guidance I'm very grateful
um Tunbridge Wells for taping the
amendment and for other members members
particularly for walthamstow and
Christchurch
um for offering their comments on it of
course I give away my horizontal friend
but uh obviously would it not be normal
to produce the draft guidance and then
consult on it rather than
expect the government to come up with
the perfect solution after it's received
representations in general I I I do
strongly urge my right honorable friend
to take the approach having draft
guidance first
well it is occasionally possible for the
government to come up with something
perfect uh straight away
um but uh but but I do accept that
doesn't always University occur and so
the process that you're in for
Christchurch just set out that is that
the government might publish a draft and
invite comments on that either
informally or via a formal consultation
uh does seem to me to be a sensible way
of arranging matters
giving way actually one of the concerns
behind a lot of this is about
consistency in the law because we know
with other forms of harassment
legislation it is already written in
about how reasonableness is defined and
I wonder if I could just invite him to
perhaps consider whether actually what
the important thing to do is not to come
up with a whole new set of guidelines
but simply to clarify the consistency in
how we expect courts and how we expect
juries to consider this concept of when
somebody claims I thought my behavior
was reasonable the law says well you
ought to have known other forms of
harassment relations so actually this
isn't about a new piece of guidance it's
about clarifying it so that we don't
inadvertently damage the ways in which
our courts can work for example I'm
looking at the CPS guidance for the
serious crime act and it talks about
defend defendants being
ought to know their course of conduct
again with oblique directions that
judges can give there's plenty of
guidance out there we really just need
to compile it into one document don't we
I really agree with what the honorable
lady for a member from Waltham so has
just said there is existing guidance in
other areas and existing practice which
quite rightly clarifies or confirms that
someone's when assessing reasonableness
that includes what somebody ought to
have known and you can of course draw
inferences from their behavior so she's
quite right to point to that existing uh
guidance and practice and I completely
agree that we should be consistent with
that and it would I'm sure looking at
that would help draw the a draft up in
an ex in a quick manner um so I think
the approach that
um a combination with the member for
walthamstow and Christchurch are both
suggested will lead us to the right
answer very quickly and enable us to
then quickly just sort of publish
something a draft and get views on that
um as the member for Christchurch
um suggested so it sounds to me like
there is a a rapid uh sensible pragmatic
and consistent Way Forward in this area
and let me turn now if I may remember
speaker to the amendment moved by
honorable friend the member for
Christchurch
um let me start on the topic of of his
good humor and I'm I've been informed by
the government whips
a source of unimpeachable reliability
obviously
um that the second reading of his
private members bill in The Other Place
regarding
um Park pitch fees uh has been
successfully passed by the other place
unopposed unopposed Madam Deputy speaker
so I hope that I hope that provides an
early and early boost to my honorable
friends good humor and one point arose
uh in his speech which doesn't relate
directly to an amendment but I think
it's important but I do want to just
respond to it
um and something I've noticed as well uh
adverts on London Underground tubes
referring to
um people uh sort of people's uh
behavior in terms of where they look and
he said that was produced by the
government and just for the sake of
clarity
um those advertisements are in fact
produced by the mayor of London
um in his capacity as the head of
Transport for London now turning to
turning to the various amendments table
by another member
um my random friend Wells has as the
house will have heard given these as you
would expect as one would expect very
close and careful consideration
um as have uh colleagues in the home
office uh we understand completely that
the member of Christchurch has made
these uh amendments or proposed these
amendments after a great deal of
consideration
um which we've taken very seriously
very seriously indeed so I'd like to go
through them
um one by one
um first of all amendments two and six
would require the other person's sex the
victim sex to have been the Principal
motivation for the defendant's behavior
um as my right another friend uh the
member for Thomas Wells has set out
um in drafting the legislation uh in the
way that he has We are following
precedent and I think it is best that
we're possible uh as a member for them
so the moment ago that we do try and be
consistent in the way
um that we uh legislate
um I think if there is any components of
the motivation
um for the defendant's Behavior Uh which
is concerned with the sex of the victim
that is in itself
um of great concern it may not be the
Principal component in some cases it may
simply be a component it may even be a
subsidiary component but that is
nonetheless
um serious the intent of the house here
is to protect people from sex-based uh
harassment and so whether or not the sex
the sex-based component is the principal
component or a subsidiary component and
it strikes me that nonetheless that
seriousness remains and that to
translate The house's intention into
legislation um
I think our feeling on balance have been
considered it very carefully and of
course discussed it and with the member
in charge of the right to remember for
Tunbridge Wells
um but we do feel the drafting uh as it
was
um best achieves the intent and is also
consistent with the rest of the statute
book
amendments three and five which
substitute
um the words
um or seek to replace the words because
of I think my honorable friend uh what
round of a friend no matter if else has
once again
um explained or set out to the house the
fact that the use of these words because
of appear in a number of other contexts
in other pieces of legislation
um and although as he said um don't
remember christchurch's uh commanded
English language and the Elegance of
expression
um cannot be uh disputed there is again
a great benefit to consistency with
other pieces of legislation and so we
feel following precedent and maintaining
that consistency
um is a is a good idea and let me turn
now to amendments um seven and eight
which would restrict the new offense
only to cases where if passed uh the
harassing behavior is done because of a
victim's actual sex and not what the
defendant presumed times the victim's
sex to be and I agree with the honor of
Christchurch getting into wider
discussions about the distinction
between sex and gender would probably
not be helpful in the context of this um
debate this afternoon or this morning
um so we're considering here a
circumstance where somebody harasses
somebody else
um in the erroneous belief that their
their gender is the opposite to what it
actually is and I think
really what matters here is is the
intent the intent to cause uh sex-based
distress and harassment and even if the
perpetrator or the alleged perpetrator
was mistaken in their assumption about
the sex of the victim or the purported
victim the complainant
um I don't think that minimizes or
mitigates the seriousness of the ACT
being undertaken the intention is there
the ACT has been undertaken the fact
that the victim or the complainant it
may not be what the perpetrator thinks
um I don't think uh mitigates or
minimizes the seriousness
um of the ACT being undertaken
um Amendment four would uh before I turn
to Amendment four there was a question
Madam depth speaker that arose in the
course of a member for christchurch's
speech that I meant to address at the
beginning of my remarks um but didn't do
so so I'd like to turn to it now
um I agree with him the member of Christ
Church on member Christchurch that
um in framing new legislation
um concerns about prison capacity should
not as he said
um constrain uh what the house may do uh
it is of course incumbent uh for
Parliament will legislate it will set
out criminal offenses the police will
investigate the crown prosecution
service will prosecute the courts will
if appropriate convict um it is then up
to the government to make sure that
adequate prison capacity
um is available and to that end I know
that my vulnerable friend the law
Chancellor and Secretary of State for
justice is engaged in a substantial
prison building program so I grew so
just one second I so I agreed on a
member of Christchurch
um that prison capacity constraints or
availability should not in any way
Fetter the house as it considers
legislation of course I give away The
Honorable gentleman is making some very
good points The Only Exception I I think
the mayor will understand has had a good
record on this general area but in terms
of prison population isn't it about the
time he did something about the Thousand
young people
convicted on a joint Enterprise that
could open up so much capacity in our
prison service
um I thank government Hospital's
intervention I think as Madam speaker
indicated that is an important point at
a mom which I'm sure the house will have
an opportunity to consider
um on another occasion but I thank him
for for raising it
um this morning
um let me turn now for my membed up
speaker to
um amendment number four which would
state that the defendant can be a man or
a woman
um I would like to take the opportunity
to Echo my right honorable friend
um in confirming clearly that the
defendant for this offense could be a
man or a woman and indeed the victim
could be a man or a woman because as
we've said
um this legislation makes no distinction
between men or women we don't in
legislation generally
um set out the permitted genders of
potential perpetrators or those that
might be guilty I think generally
speaking
um almost every perhaps not quite every
but almost every offense is capable of
being committed by either a man or a
woman we don't generally speaking and
need to say so on the face of the bill
uh and I don't think we need to say so
here
um either but I'm happy to make clear
from the dispatch box that it is Our
intention
um obviously as with almost every piece
of legislation that either a man or a
woman could be guilty of committing this
uh offense and the member for
Christchurch and The Honorable
Christchurch
um is quite right
um to raise this issue and seek this
clarification which I'm happy happy to
give
um let me finally Madame dip speaker
turn to Amendment nine requiring the
bill to come into force on August the
1st of this year I completely share
you're a member for Christchurch annual
member for wolfenstow's
um desire to get this bill activated
quickly it sometimes for them if I'm
speaking candidly it sometimes
frustrates me as a minister that it
takes longer to get things done than
perhaps it ought to so I do share the
sentiment expressed
um there is as the writing member for
Tunbridge Wells said earlier
um some uncertainty in the timing
through the passage in the hell of the
bill to the House of Lords obviously
that their little ships in the other
place regulate their own business and we
can't be certain about how their
Lordships May seek to dispose of this
legislation there is also the question
around the guidance that we've discussed
already and the desire to make sure we
uh or the suggestion that we publish a
draft and people then comment upon that
and which will take a little bit of time
I hope it is a few months but um you
know I don't want to create a tripwire
that we inadvertently
um stumble over so um I would like to
proceed or suggest to the house that we
proceed as is ordinarily the case in
primary legislation with commencement or
often the case with a commencement via a
statutory instrument but with the
undertaking uh from the government's
point of view uh that the firm
undertaking given given here today that
we will seek to do this as soon as
possible
um because this bill clearly commands in
principle very widespread support across
the house and for the sake of protecting
uh women and men it's important that we
get this onto the statute books and
operational and effective as quickly as
we possibly can
the question is that new Clause 1 be
read a second time as many as are of
that opinions
no I think the eyes have it the eyes
have it the question is that new Clause
won't be added to the bill as many as
are of that opinion say I I the country
no and I think the eyes have it the eyes
have it uh Amendment one Greg Clarke to
move formally
the question is that the amendment be
made as many as I of that opinion say
aye
aye the country no I think the eyes have
it the eyes have it uh consideration
completed third reading what day no
the question is that the bill be now
sorry Greg Clark to move third reading
thank you very much indeed um we're
we're taking the honorable gentleman's
injunctions to to speed to progress with
dispatcher even further than uh is uh
has presently I beg to move that the
bill will be now read for a third time
uh I'm very grateful I should say for
the uh debates that we've had in
committee and in the house this morning
um the the Amendments that have been
accepted by the house this morning I
think reflect a substantial debate we
had in committee and I'm grateful to my
honorable friends for his amendments
which have afforded us the opportunity
uh to clarify some important aspects of
the bill and to have some uh commitments
made from the dispatch books which will
be useful to us uh if as I hope the bill
continues to make a progress
um we've taken uh sometime this morning
and I'm conscious that other colleagues
have other bills that they are anxious
to progress and if they are to be
properly scrutinized it requires me to
be brief if the house decides to give
this bill a third reading today it will
be an historic day for the first time in
our history deliberately harassing
following shouting degrading words at
making obscene gestures at women and
girls in public places and yes on
occasion men and boys in public places
because of their sex with the intention
the deliberate intention to cause them
alarm or distress will be a specific
offense and a serious one at that
punishing thing is that it hasn't been
so until now many years after it was
made an aggravated offense to harass
someone in public on the grounds of
their race their religion or their
sexuality for example indeed indeed
women and it is mostly women but the
bill does apply to men have had to alter
the way that they live their lives
to walk home using different routes to
arrange to be accompanied rather than to
walk alone to have or to pretend to have
conversations on a mobile phone whilst
walking alone to hold Keys clenched in
their fists in their hands as a
safeguard and indeed so prevalent is
this that in visiting a sixth form of
one of my local schools a few weeks ago
young men and women they're 17 and 18. I
asked how many people in the in the
class of students typically walked home
with the keys in their hands instantly
without conferring every young woman in
the hand in the in the class put their
hand up not a single young man did and
they expressed some mystification that
this happened at all such are the
changes and accommodations that
sometimes some consciously have been
made because of the potential and the
reality of harassment in public our
streets belong to women just as much as
they belong to men women should be able
to use our streets as confidently and
safely as men do free from abuse free
from humiliation free from violence
physical or verbal this bill makes a
specific but important step
harassing women in the streets or men
and boys in if if it applies to them
with the intention to degrade or to
terrify them isn't normal it isn't
natural it isn't Just The Way of the
World
it's a crime and it's a serious one at
that this bill will address that anomaly
will move our legislation forward I
commend it to the house
the question is that the bill being I
read the third time at Stella Creasy
this bill has been a long time in
gestation
it reflects years and years of
campaigning about a very simple concept
that the member for our Tunbridge Wells
is articulated very clearly there and
the surprise that those who are not
affected by it feel when they realize it
and see it misogyny is driving crimes
against women and girls
a very simple statement but a very clear
recognition in this legislation for the
first time ever that women are being
targeted simply because they are women
that young girls in our society walk
with their keys get asked well what were
you wearing told not to get on buses at
certain type of night to be frightened
to be wary in a way that young men don't
now I want to address head on the point
made by the member for Christchurch
because I agree with him we have got to
stand up for our young men
we've got to stand up for the bulk of
young men who know when they see that
and when they realize what is happening
to their sisters to their mums to their
friends in school their aunties their
cousins how awful it must be that 51 of
our society does not have the same
freedom to go about their daily business
those young men deserve better than the
idea that somehow this kind of behavior
is inevitable that boys will be boys so
in passing this legislation today we are
standing up not just literally because
this legislation does cover both men and
women equally but also for that quite
majority of young men and older men who
recognize this behavior is completely
unacceptable that it is Criminal and
that for too long nothing has been done
about it and I know the member from
Christchurch will be somebody who cares
very much about the actual evidence so
let me just give him the detail because
where those police forces have been
treating crimes that are motivated by
sex or presume sex seriously and
recording that data the story they tell
is very compelling for why this
legislation matters 12 out of 43 police
forces in England and Wales now use this
policy
crime survey of England Wales found
there were 67
000 reports of hate crime based on
gender between March 2015 and 2018. 57
57 000 of those were targeted at women
the police forces started off the
Nottinghamshire under the leadership of
Sue fish and I hope we can all in this
house pay tribute to sue fish and the
tremendous work she's done in
recognizing the benefits to policing of
taking this approach
show very clearly the difference in that
same time period Nottinghamshire police
received 269 reports of misogyny 125 of
those were classed as hate crime and 144
were classed as non-crime incidences
of the 265 misogyny hate Crime Victims
243 were female
the same pattern in Avon and Somerset
where just over 90 percent of the
victims were female but men did come
forward too so we know that men will be
able to use this legislation
my point in raising this is not to say
that somehow it does not matter that
young men might experience sex spaced
harassment it's to recognize that at the
moment in our society it is women who
are paying the price for our failure to
understand how misogyny has driven
crimes against them and to recognize
that within the law and what this law
will do because of that imbalance is
correct that and bring us that
opportunity not just to record that data
but finally acknowledge that in the
courts and in doing so stand up for all
those young men who do not want to see
this Behavior who do recognize that it
is abuse and harassment who do recognize
that their sisters their mothers their
aunts their cousins their friends at
school deserve the same freedoms to go
about their daily business as they do
this legislation this concept of
recognizing equally as we do with other
protected characteristics that there are
those out there who perpetrate crimes
because of their hatred and their anger
towards somebody who is of a diff
because of their sex or their presumed
sex it's about equality of emancipation
and I say to the member for Christchurch
who I know will be deeply concerned as I
was by the reports of sexual harassment
amongst his own police force in Dorset
one of the reasons why many of us have
campaigned for this legislation and
campaigned for this recognition is the
evidence we've had from the police
forces that are doing it of just how
transformative it is because let's be
very clear we're not talking about new
forms of crime but we are talking about
changing a culture in which women coming
forward to report crime have been told
well that's just life we couldn't really
find this person
not everybody who follows a woman down a
road shouting abuse suggesting that they
might want to touch them in various
sorts of ways and somehow that is an
appropriate way to introduce yourself to
them becomes a rapist or a sexual abuser
but many of those who are rapists and
sexual abusers do start with this sort
of behavior
this kind of data that this legislation
will allow us to gather helps us detect
and prevent crimes it helps us to change
the culture within policing and in this
week of all weeks we know how important
that will be to the safety of everybody
in our constituencies
I share with the member for Christchurch
that deep concern about the role models
our young men have I look on with horror
at the material that Andrew Tate has
promoted I look on horror the things you
can find online that we know our young
men are consuming but I have great faith
in the young men of this country they
don't need to be closeted or nanied they
need us to stand up on the air ability
to be good allies to be good Brothers
good Fathers good friends good work
colleagues that they are not likely to
behave in these ways so those who do
need to feel the force of the law and
the law needs to be on the side of those
victims in recognizing that behavior in
the way that we do with other forms of
hate crime by passing this legislation
we are sending a powerful message to our
young men that they do deserve better
than that caricature of boys will be
boys that they do deserve better than
the idea that they somehow couldn't help
them so cells because we know that they
can and we know that it's as much about
our young men and the message we send
them as it is our young women and their
freedoms that we are fighting for today
in this legislation and that is why I
welcome the fact that this has been done
in a cross-party basis it's why I pay
tribute to Citizens UK and our streets
now and the faucet Society for the work
that they have done to make the argument
that we shouldn't minimize harassment in
public we should recognize it treat it
equally and prosecute those who behave
in those ways and I suspect across the
house there is a common agreement at how
much this debate is changing we are all
of a certain age we remember things that
were on television when we were younger
that now we know would not be acceptable
I see obviously a gentleman obviously is
shaking his head and and I'm sure
afterwards we can compare notes on just
how awful on 90s fashion was but we
remember things that were on television
and cultural ideas about race and
ethnicity that now we would recognize
our inappropriate and indeed create a
culture in which racial hatred and abuse
is encouraged
we hope in time by treating targeting
people on the basis of their sex or
presume sex will have the same effect
that we can challenge those myths and
challenge those expectations and
challenge that behavior but we cannot do
that if the law is not on the side of
those women who haven't come forward to
date the 80 of women who experience
street-based harassment who don't report
it this legislation will change it it
will also support those young men and it
will also support our society to be the
better version of itself I hope members
here will support this legislation this
is the start of a process and I hope the
minister will talk about the training
that will be given to the police and the
CPS to make sure that this legislation
is effective
but let's have no more minimization no
more shaking our heads and saying it's
just the way of the world teaching young
women to be frightened to go on
self-defense courses to maybe travel
with their friends to carry those keys
any more than we say to young men well
try not to do it again
let's change that culture let's change
the law and let's make this a society
where everybody is just free to live
their lives in peace because our wager
left or right that is an ambition we can
all get behind
at Jackie Doyle prize Adam Deputy
speaker I'll be very brief this morning
but I couldn't let this legislation pass
without passing comment particularly as
The Honorable ladies just referred to in
the week that we've seen the Casey
review which actually again reminds us
reminds all of us just how every day and
experience sexual harassment is for so
many women and girls and I'm really
grateful to my right honorable friend
for for the fact that he's taken up this
course because you know in the 13 years
I've been here we've talked a lot about
these things we've talked a lot about
violence against women and girls but it
hasn't got much beyond words when it
actually comes to concrete action
there's been much resistance to this
measure because of the pre you know the
additional pressures it might bring to
the police
and in resisting this measure this place
was sending a message out to women and
girls that this was their lot it was
normalizing that behavior and what the
Casey review actually shows is that in
normalizing that behavior in society we
give a green light to that behavior
within our Police Services who are
exactly the people who should be keeping
us safe so this legislation for me marks
a real turning point and it makes Mark's
a real tell anybody that actually at
last
we are sending a message that actually
no we are not going to put up with this
you know this is not acceptable behavior
it should not be accessible behavior for
anyone to be experiencing harassment and
nobody should think that they can get
away with it nobody should be using
their power and you know making people
feel uncomfortable and distressed just
because they can so I am hugely grateful
to my article for mp3 so I just really
grateful that the government have
embraced this and give it support I
think it's a real it's a rare moment of
unity when we're all on the same side on
this and uh you know for women I think I
hope that this marks just the beginning
of many more measures that really give
us the opportunity to enjoy
participating in the society without
having to put up with this intimidation
day in Day Out
uh Peter Gibbs actually speak it's a
pleasure to be called to speak in this
debate and I once again congratulate my
right to award friend the member for
Tunbridge Wells on bringing forward this
important and hugely welcome bill which
will better protect all of our
constituents as I outlined in my second
reading speech in respect of this bill
we have a long Heritage of protective
legislation brought by conservative
governments the children's act the
protection from harassment act the
protection of freedoms at the Modern
slavery act The Domestic Abuse Act and
even my own private hire and taxi
legislation or Shan's law
add to this the range of loss my
rentable friends bill which we are
debating today I also sincerely look
forward to seeing very soon the draft
legislation on Banning conversion
practices as promised by the government
which will add further to these range of
protections Madam Deputy speaker I
appreciate that time is short today so I
will conclude by congratulating my
remnable friend for bringing this bill
forward for its third reading and I'm
happy to give it my full support Louis
French thank you madam Deputy speaker
and also be brief given the time limits
today and I Rise to support this bill to
provide greater protection from
sex-based harassment and I also thank
the honorable member for Tunbridge Wells
for all of his great work and all those
campaigners out that have campaigned so
hard but in doing so and in this brief
time that I've got today can I please
urge the minister again to review the
Metropolitan Police is Tried by our
policing model which was highlighted in
baroness Casey's review which
highlighting a number of issues this
week but in particular in relevance to
this bill it highlights with the 50 50
more sexual offenses occur in the
Southeast BCU area which includes my
home of Bexley compared to that of the
central Norfolk which includes the likes
of Camden and Islington
yet the resourcing model was baroness
Casey highlights is the same for both
bcus under this one size fits-all
policing model which was introduced by
the mayor of London this is not right
and alongside the mayor's disastrous
Euler's plans which would impact many
women traveling home at night and their
safety kind of please urge the minister
again to look into this matter of the
Triborough policing model thank you
very soon Adam Deputy speaker I realized
very briefly to congrats play The
Honorable Gentleman on introducing this
bill that I wanted to be a man on this
side supporting from the back benches
because we have some very able women
who've LED this campaign on this side
and I didn't want to me is this because
I have a vested interest Madam Deputy
speaker I have a daughter of daughters
Lucy Mega Lucy Madeleine Verity I have
granddaughters Megan Lola Gwen elegy
Rosa and almond they'll go us and I want
them to grow up in a world where this
abuse no longer at the fifth
that's Elaine Saxby thank you madam
Deputy speaker I warmly welcome this
bill from my right honorable friend the
member for Tunbridge Wells too many
women and even more concerningly many
girls have experienced a form of
sex-based harassment in public places
the government's own call for evidence
ahead of our violence against women and
girls strategy received 180 000
responses showing the depth and breadth
of feeling amongst British women on
their safety and exposure to harassment
when they are just going about their
daily lives
as part of this strategy Barnstable in
my North Devon constituency has received
348 000 pounds of safer Street funding
to tackle violence against women and
girls I know my police and crime
commissioner and local Force have been
tackling these crimes which act as
barriers to women and girls enjoying
their local community I just wanted to
take the opportunity to thank my right
honorable friend for his work and the
opportunity to place on the record my
support for this important bill
at Dr Karen Mullen thank you madam
Deputy speaker I'll also speak briefly
and begin by playing tribute tomorrow
Uncle friend for securing uh the passage
of this bill and I think it's been great
to hear
um it won't be supporting the house
today and I arrived primarily to pay
tribute actually to a group of girls who
really helped me understand this issue
uh sandbach High School is not in my
constituency it's a constitution of the
member of congleton but she very kindly
agreed for me to visit it because so
many of my constituents go to school
there and I had a session it's a girls
school with a group of girls who really
put across to me how much of a frequent
issue it was for them even at this point
in their lives and how commonplace it
was for them to experience that
harassment and and also to contribute to
a charity and crew called motherwell
founded by Kate Blakemore because I
think what we discussed today is
recognizing this sits within a bigger
picture of how we think and treat women
and girls in society and motherwell is a
women and girls charity dedicated to
empowering women in all sorts of
different ways including and looking at
issues of their own safety and
um that organize that group of girls
really helped me understand this issue
and I'm pleased to be here today to pay
tribute to them and pay tribute to my
honorable friend in supporting this bill
Shadow Secretary of State
thank you madam Deputy speaker I made my
thanks previously to those who've done
such an excellent job at bringing this
legislation to the house and so I will
be very brief but I wanted to underline
I think an incredibly important point
that was made by a number of speakers
this bill will be positive for everyone
and obviously the evidence for this has
already been set out including a moment
to go by uh the right honorable member
for Tunbridge Wells when we look at the
evidence around the impact of this kind
of behavior especially on girls I know
all of us in this house are incredibly
concerned girl guiding found that a
third of girls aged 17 and 18 first
experienced harassment at at the age of
11.
now it will be good for girls and for
women and for boys and men to be clear
that the atrocious behavior of a
minority is something that is truly
truly rejected by the majority therefore
this is important legislation now while
it's very good this bill has government
support I would say it's a shame that
some of these very important issues do
seem to quite often at the moment be
relegated to private members bills that
is two years since the violence against
women and girls strategy was launched
and we haven't seen enough progress we
do need to see more yes this bill is
positive but we also need to see
misogyny being made a hate crime we need
to see specialist rape courts across the
country we need to see domestic abuse
specialists in every 999 room and we
ultimately need to see across government
approach because while it's absolutely
right that we focused in this bill on
criminal justice and policing matters
the solution is going to be found more
widely as well in our schools hospitals
and workplaces and not delivering that
solution will feel women and girls thank
you madam Deputy speaker Minister Chris
um thank you madam speaker I'll be
extremely brief as I know there are many
other members wanting to bring bills
forward uh today and other members have
made uh excellent contributions look I'd
like to just quickly congratulate again
the running member for Tunbridge Wells
uh for bringing forward this legislation
uh for the work that many members have
done on this uh particularly the member
for walthamstown the member of course
for thurrock as well and many others uh
it's important that this is only one
part of a wider piece of work to protect
uh women and girls in particular of
course this is a government that brought
forward legislation on forced marriage
on stalking on upskirting uh making sure
that serious sexual offenders spend more
of their sentence in prison we've
brought forth a Domestic Abuse Act
introduced the domestic abuse
commissioner and legislated on female
genital mutilation there is of course a
lot more work to do and I look forward
to working with colleagues in government
and colleagues across the house to make
further progress
delivered at the house cycle Greg Dr
windup thank you very much indeed my
name this week I'll be very brief and
just want to add my thanks to all of
those who have been aiding the passage
of the bill so far and to start with
thanking my constituents who over the
years have shared with me their
experiences and have encouraged me to
bring forward this legislation supported
by campaigning groups right across the
the country
in in turning those intentions into
prospective legislation one requires
advice and support and I'm very grateful
to officials in the home office and
ministers from the previous Home
Secretary the right honorable member for
Whitton to the current Home Secretary
and her ministerial team
um the the member for Derby Dales who
has seen this bill through its previous
stages has been indisposed today I'd
want to put on record my thanks to her
and and my thanks to my right number
friends the member for Croydon South for
his very able picking up of the brief
today and responding to the report stage
of the bill we're very grateful to him
for that can I also thank the excellent
Clerks of the of the house uh in
particular if I may single out the Clark
responsible for private member spills uh
Henry Griffiths who does a tremendous
job supported by her very able uh
colleagues we're very grateful for the
advice that she's given and finally can
I uh thank the no less able whip that is
responsible for uh Siri whips on both
sides I should say but in particular the
member for Castle points who has
developed a particular reputation for
sensing the mood of the house and being
able to guide and bring us a house that
sometimes can be a form them for
contention my honorable friend has a
great skill in being able to bring us
together on occasions like this and so
having put a record uh my thanks can I
commend this bill to the house
well I think the right honorable
gentleman Anne-Marie Griffith was here
earlier she will be back but we will
ensure that she is aware of your kind
words the question is that the bill be
now read the third time as many as are
of that opinion say I
country no and I think the eyes have it
the eyes have it